HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE TODAY WE HAVE
NINE BILLS ON THE AGENDA WITH
FIVE BILLS ON CONSENT.
AS A REMINDER WE LIMIT TESTIMONY
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EACH WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WE ALSO TO GIVE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION WE'RE GOING TO
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
WE OBVIOUSLY DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
BUT I DO SEE AN AUTHOR MY
FAVORITE SENATOR CONNIE LEIVA
COME ON UP.
ON ITEM NUMBER NINE SB.
SEVEN THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
AND HAPPY TO BE HERE AN EXCITED
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME ACTUALLY
PRESENTING ON THIS BILL.
SB SEVEN THIRTY FIVE WOULD
REQUIRE TO SPECIFIC ELEMENTS.
THAT APPLICATION AND REDO
TERMINATION FORMS FOR PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS INCLUDE A
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER THE
APPLICANT NEEDS ACCOMMODATIONS.
DUE TO A DISTURBED DISABILITY OR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EXPERIENCE
ONCE AN INDIVIDUAL HAS ALREADY
TOLD THE CASE WORKER THAT THEY
NEED ACCOMMODATIONS THE FIRST
PAGE OF THEIR CASE FILE WILL
ALERT.
ANY OTHER CASE WORKER THAT THE
APPLICANTS NEED THE NECESSARY
ACCOMMODATIONS CURRENTLY COUNTY
SHOES THE STATEWIDE AUTOMATED
WELFARE SYSTEM SAWS TO MANAGE
ENROLLMENT ELIGIBILITY FOR CAL
FIRST CAL WORKS MEDI CAL AND
GENERAL ASSISTANCE AMONG OTHER
THINGS.
UNFORTUNATELY.
SOME FORMS FOR THESE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS DO NOT ASK ABOUT THE
APPLICANTS NEED FOR DISABILITY
OR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ACCOMMODATIONS.
SO THOSE APPLICANTS MAY NOT EVEN
BE AWARE THAT CERTAIN
ACCOMMODATIONS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
THEM.
WHEN TRYING TO ACCESS MUCH
NEEDED ASSISTANCE IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
AND SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE?
RECEIVED ACCOMMODATIONS THEY
NEED WITHOUT HAVING TO
CONSTANTLY DISCLOSE OUR
SITUATION.
IN ADDITION LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN WHICH MEANS THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME SSI RECIPIENTS.
WERE SIXTY FIVE OR OLDER OR
PEOPLE OF ANY AGE WHO ARE BLIND
DISABLE OR DISABLED WILL BE
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR AND
RECEIVE CAL FRESH BENEFITS.
THIS CHANGE HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
CREATE AN INFLUX OF NEW
APPLICANTS AND RECIPIENTS WHO
MADE NEED ACCOMMODATIONS.
GIVEN THE ALREADY HIGH CASELOAD
FOR WORKERS.
SB SEVEN THIRTY FIVE ENSURES
THAT A PRACTICAL AND EFFECTIVE
PROCESS IS IN PLACE TO IDENTIFY
BENEFICIARIES WHO MAY NEED
ACCOMMODATIONS TO DO THEIR
DISABILITY OR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EXPERIENCE.
TODAY WITH ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS KEVIN AS ALONG FROM
THE CAL COALITION OF WHERE FOR
RIGHTS ASSOCIATION ORG
ORGANIZATION.
ORGANIZATION EXCUSE ME.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I THINK WHAT WE DID BEFORE
WE HAVE WHICH BEFORE WE HAVE.
THE FIRST WITNESS WHEN WE STATUS
OF A QUORUM.
RENTS UP HERE MATHIS.
ARAMBULA.
CHOI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
STONE.
A QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
AND WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE DOCTOR ARAMBULA SECONDS BY
MR MATHIS ALL RIGHT FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
WELL KEVIN OTHER COALITION
CALIFORNIA OPERATES
ORGANIZATIONS -- THIS BILL
BASICALLY RIGHT DON'T.
THAT THE SYSTEM EXIST FOR CAL
WORKS IN WHICH IS ONE EXPAND
THAT THE MEDI CAL.
AND SO SITE GIVEN THE FACT THAT
LOWER DISABLE PEOPLE ARE GETTING
ON MEDICARE NOW.
AND URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS A
COMMITTEE JUST GIVE OUR LOW
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BETTER CHECKER CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS TO MATHIS
CENTER GRAY BILL I'D LOVE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR WE WILL BE HAPPY TO
ADD YOU THINK YOU SIR.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS VERY GOOD OF SOME SURE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY
DOCTOR ARAMBULA SECOND BY MISTER
MATHIS.
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RES I
MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I'D
CHOI.
TôI I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE.
IT'S FIVE TO ZERO WE WILL BE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENSOR SKINNER.
ON SB FOUR SEVENTEEN ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT THE BILL.
MADAM SENATOR THAT THE SUPPORT
SUPPORT.
HOW EXCELLENT THANK YOU?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS -- WITH THAT
GREAT -- MOTION AND I THINK
YOU'LL APPRECIATE THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL TO HELP PROTECT OUR
CONSUMERS TO RECEIVE CAL FRINGE
BENEFITS TO BENEFIT FROM THE
FEDERAL PILOT THAT IT STARTED
ITH THAT -- SEE IF I HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DESK ABOUT
LOW THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WE ARE A SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT --
THAT CURRENTLY EBT CANNOT BE
USED ELECTRONIC BENEFIT TRANSFER
STE -- PAYMENT CANNOT BE USED
ONLINE AND THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S A
SPECIAL PIN CODE -- AND AND IT'S
TO PROTECT THE CONSUMER -- FROM
HAVING THEIR BENEFITS STOLEN --
THE PROPOSED.
AS PILOTS THAT ARE HAPPENING IN
OTHER STATES ALLOW SOMEBODY TO
PURCHASE THINGS ONLINE BUT WE
FEEL LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS FOR CALIFORNIA FIGURE OUT --
WITH REGARDS TO CASH BENEFITS
AND HOW THEY'LL BE USED ONLINE --
MAKING SURE THAT THE FOOD
PURCHASED THROUGH -- ONLINE
PURCHASES IS IS SAFE AND HEALTHY --
AND THAT.
THE DELIVERY FEES ARE EXORBITANT
OR OR OR MORE COSTLY FOR THE
POOR A COMMUNITIES -- AND SO
THIS BILL BASICALLY ESTABLISHES --
DIRECTION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO ESTABLISH --
A CONVERSATION A TABLE WHERE WE
CAN ALL COME TOGETHER AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT THOSE.
THAT KIND OF NEW ABILITY TO
PURCHASE ONLINE LOOKS LIKE AND
HOW WE BEST PROTECT OUR
CONSUMERS THIS STATE AND THIS
BODY THE LEGISLATURE HAVE LED
THE WAY IN AB T..
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND THIS IS
JUST ONE MORE WAY THAT WE HOPE
THAT YOU WILL DO SO AND WITH
THAT WE ARE DURABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
AND BEFORE WE GO BACK TO MEMBERS
CENTER YOU ARE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS TODAY CORRECT YES
APOLOGIES FOR NOT OPENING WITH
THAT ALRIGHT.
ANYTHING FROM MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER IT IS
WHAT -- AS A SENATOR IF SHE
WOULD PLEASE ACCEPT ME AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL I THINK IT'S
MOVES IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND I WAS EXCITED TO READ THE
LANGUAGE AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA
CERTAINLY IS NEEDED THANK YOU
FOR WELCOMING YES I WOULD ACCEPT
YOU AS A CO AUTHOR.
IRAQ THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY WE HAVE A YEAH.
WELL CLOSING REMARKS FROM THE
SENATOR ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
RIGHT YES.
MATHIS MATHIS I ARAMBULA.
CHOI.
CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON I AM MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE.
SENATE YOUR BILL AS A FOUR ZERO
ALL HOLD IT OPEN FOR MISSING
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
AND CENTER DORADO MY SAYING THAT
CORRECTLY SENATOR.
I BELIEVE BOTH YOUR BILLS HAVE
SUPPORT SUPPORTS AS WELL
[inaudible]
ANYTHING.
IS THAT A YES.
IT WHICHEVER BILL YOU LIKE TO
START WITH -- WORKS. FIFTY THREE
IT WILL START WITH THREE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE OUR YES IT'S VERY
SHORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THREE SIXTY FIVE CHANGES --
CALIFORNIA WORK OPPORTUNITY
RESPONSIBILITY TO KIDS CAL WORKS
IMMEDIATE NEEDS STATUTE TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT PARENTS ARE
REQUIRED CHILD CARE IN ORDER TO
WORK OR PARTICIPATE.
IN EDUCATION OR TRAINING
ACTIVITY ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE
CHILD CARE ASSISTANCE WHEN IT'S
NEEDED THE MOST.
THIS MEASURES DESIGNED TO HELP
HARD WORKING INDIVIDUALS KEEP
THEIR JOBS AND THEIR EDUCATIONAL
ALL OPPORTUNITIES ALTHOUGH MANY
WORKING PARENTS ARE ELIGIBLE AND
EVENTUALLY APPROVED FOR CAL
WORKS CHILD CARE ASSISTANCE.
SOMETIMES IT'S TOO LATE AND THIS
LACK OF CHILDCARE RESULTS IN JOB
LOSS.
OF TODAY WE HAVE UP HERE AS
WITNESSES KEVIN OF LANI IN AND
JUST AGO BIRTH FOLLOW.
THE KEVIN AS THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA WHAT RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS THE REASON WE
WORKING ON THIS BILL IS BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD.
A SEVERAL FAMILIES THAT CAME
INTO OFFICE.
BECAUSE COMPLAINING THAT THEY
HAD A JOB THEY NEED A CHILD CARE
THEY COULDN'T GET THE CHAKA THE
TOOK THIRTY DAYS THAT OFF THE
JOB WE THOUGHT THAT WAS A
HORRIBLE THING.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE THE BILL
WE ORIGINAL VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DISCOVERED LOWER THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY ALSO A SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND AND AGREE WE'VE HEARD
FROM CLIENTS WHO HAD THIS VERY
SITUATION AND THEY END UP
STAYING ON A LONGER -- WHEN THEY
LOSE THEIR JOB AND THEIR KIDS
ARE ARE LESS WELL OFF AND SO
THIS IS ACTUALLY I'M NOT ONLY
GOOD POLICY BUT ALSO A GOOD
INVESTMENT?
SAID THANK YOU AND WE ARE DRIVE
BELT.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME FORWARD STATE YOUR
NAME.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WE CAN SEE CHRISTIAN SENT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
HEARING IS SAYING NONE BUT BRING
IT BACK TO THE BODY.
MR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI.
OKAY SENATOR -- I I HAVE GREASY
MOST OF FROM A MORE TRUSTING --
YOU ARE.
REQUIRING COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
THE A CHILD CARE ASSISTANCE SO
DOES THAT MEAN THAT THE 100%
COUNTY SO WOULD PROVIDE THE THE
CASH ALLOWANCE SO OR HOW HOW DO
THEY HELP WITH THAT THE WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN AND HOW LONG.
IN A HOME WITH THAT THAT THE
MONEY WOULD BE REIMBURSED -- TO
COUNTIES HELP FROM THE STATE
THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS OKAY
JUST REAL QUICK AND THEN YOU CAN
REALLY FEEL IT AND BUT THIS IS --
BASICALLY TO JUST -- ESTABLISH
THE ELIGIBILITY QUICKER RATHER
THAN WAIT THE THIRTY DAYS THAT'S
THE CHANGE THAT WERE ASKING FOR
BECAUSE THEY END UP BEING
ELIGIBLE.
BUT GETS DONE SO SLOW THIRTY
DAYS LATER THAT THEY'VE ALREADY
LOST THE UP EITHER LOST THEIR
JOB OR THEY LOST IT BUT
PARTICIPATING THE TRAINING
PROGRAM SO IT'S TO SPEED UP WHAT
WOULD BE ELIGIBILITY ANYWAY.
BUT TO DO IT SOONER IF YOU KNOW
YOU'LL BE YOU'LL BE IN REQUIRE
SUCH A MEDIA -- CHILD CARE
SERVICES SO SO THAT MEANS UP
BRING IT UP.
SOONER RIGHT AND THAT THAT THE
LENGTH THAT WILL BE EXTENDED TO
MY THINKING.
IF THAT'S THE CASE THERE ARE BE
ADDITIONAL COST. TO THE COUNTY
WHETHER THAT -- COST WOULD BE
REIMBURSED BY THE STATE.
HOW LONG WILL THAT PERIOD TO BE?
WITH THIS WILL COST BECAUSE THE
TRAILER BILL RIGHT NOW PROVIDES
THERE'S A NEW TRAILER BILL THE
BUDGET PASSED.
IN A PROVIDES THAT YOU GET STAGE.
ONE FROM THE MINUTE THAT YOU
NEED CHAO KILLA YOU CAN STAGE
ONE FOR ONE WHOLE YEAR.
AND THAT'S ALL PAID FOR SO THERE
WILL BE NO COUNTY COSTS. FOR
CLARIFICATION ACTUALLY WITHIN
THE BUDGET BILLS THAT WE VOTED
ON THERE'S FUNDING THERE SO THE
STATE WOULD BE PAYING FOR THE
COST -- ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS
OCCURRED WITH THE CENTER I THINK
IT'S A GREAT DEAL I'D LOVE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU.
AND THIS IS NOT EXTENDING WHAT
OR ALREADY THE RULES IT'S JUST
BILL.
OF FAST FORWARDING THE
ELIGIBILITY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS OF THAT THIS IS GOOD I'VE
SEEN THIS IN MY DISTRICT -- AND
EVEN DURING MY TIME DURING
COLLEGE.
AND SO MANY PEOPLE HAVING THE
ABILITY. TO AFTER SCHOOL BE ABLE
TO GET THAT JOB AND THEN HAVE
CHILDREN -- AND AND BALANCE THE
HOLY ENTIRE THING YOU KNOW WHAT
I HAVE THAT DAY CARE.
RIGHT AWAY FOR SAYS HAVING TO BE
ON A WAIT LIST IS TREMENDOUSLY
HELPFUL AND GETS THESE FAMILIES
THAT ARE IN NEED WORKING SOONER
RIGHT -- AND CONTRIBUTING IN
THEIR TAX DOLLARS BACK TO THE
STATE TO PAY FOR PROGRAMS LIKE
THIS THANK YOU THANK --
CURRENTLY WE DO NOT HAVE A
MOTION.
SEC.
AND THE SECOND.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL --
CLOSING REMARKS.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RAY S..
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA.
CHOI.
CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON I'D MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE.
CENTER FOR ZERO WILL KEEP THE
CALL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LEAVE YOUR NEXT BILL IS SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY EIGHT THIS
ALSO AS A SUPPORT SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SECOND.
THANK YOU WELL -- I COULD JUST
SAY VERY QUICKLY -- MEMBERS --
THE NINETY EIGHT SB THREE NINETY
EIGHT UPDATES THE STATE LAW
REGARDING CALIFORNIA'S
PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY AGENCY.
TO REFLECT RECENT UPDATES TO
FEDERAL REGULATIONS REGARDING
PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY.
AGENCIES -- I WOULD JUST.
LET ME INTRODUCE OUR WITNESSES
KERR CHILD OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND THEN THEY ARE
RIVERA OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER. SIX A BUTCHER
CHECKER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AS YOU KNOW WE ARE
THE PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE THE LARGEST --
SUCH ORGANIZATION IN THE NATION --
ARE -- THIRTY DERIVES -- IN
LARGE PART FROM FEDERAL LAW AND
WE HAVE WITHIN THAT -- FEDERAL
LAW THREE SEPARATE -- PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT -- GIVE US
AUTHORITY -- TO BASICALLY --
ENTER INTO IN THE FACILITY AND
GET RECORDS IN THOSE FACILITIES
WHERE WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A
PERSON WITH A DISABILITY THAT
MAY BE SUBJECT TO ABUSE OR
NEGLECT WE HAVE HISTORICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA CODIFIED -- THOSE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS IN AND IN
STATE LAWS SO THIS BILL DOES --
JUST THAT WITH THE LAST SET OF
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THAT WERE
ADOPTED IN. TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN SO THIS CONFORMS -- WITH --
WITH FEDERAL LAW AND IT
CONTINUES TO PROVIDE WE THINK
THE NECESSARY TRANSPARENCY IN
STATE LAW -- SO THAT WE CAN
AVOID ANY DISPUTES ON THOSE
VISITS TO FACILITIES THAT WE
ULTIMATELY -- NEED TO VISIT THE
OTHER THING THAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT CLARIFIES THAT A FACILITY
OR PROGRAM ALSO INCLUDES --
THOSE FACILITIES USED TO HOUSE --
OR DETAIN INDIVIDUALS AND AND
IMMIGRATION DETENTION CENTERS --
SO THIS -- CLARIFIES THAT WE
HAVE THAT AUTHORITY AS WELL AND
WE'VE BEEN USING THAT WITH A
LITTLE MORE -- REGULARITY -- AS
WE'VE MADE SOME VISITS INTO FOR
EXAMPLE ADELANTO AND PRODUCED A
REPORT FROM THERE BUT ALSO IN
THE YOUTH FACILITIES OPERATED BY
OR ON OUR WE ARE CHAIR I VOTE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
ANDREA RIVERA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB -- THREE NINETY
EIGHT AND THIS BILL WOULD HELP
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DETAINED AND
IMMIGRANT DETENTION CENTERS AND
SUFFER FROM A MENTAL IMPAIRMENT
OR ILLNESS ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE --
THE SERVICES THAT THEY REQUIRE
NOT ONLY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
BUT LEGAL SERVICES AS WELL.
BY EXPANDING THE CURRENT
DEFINITION OF A FACILITY --
PROGRAMMING CALIFORNIA'S
ADVOCACY AGENCY LAWS WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WILL GAIN ACCESS TO
THE SERVICES THAT THEY REQUIRE.
IN -- TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB ONE OH
THREE WHICH DIRECTS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO MONITOR AND PRODUCE
REPORTS ON THE CONDITIONS THAT
ARE FOUND IN IMMIGRANT DETENTION
FACILITIES AND OUR STATE -- THE
AG'S OFFICE ISSUED THEIR FIRST
REPORT AND FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR
AND THEY FOUND THAT DETAINEES
HAVE -- MULTIPLE BARRIERS WHEN
ATTEMPTING TO ACCESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
FEDERAL OFFICIALS ALSO REPORT
THAT APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS -- WHO HAVE MENTAL
ILLNESSES AND ARE IN THESE
FACILITIES DO NOT GET THE ACCESS
THAT THEY DESERVE?
ALSO -- I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT GIVEN THE CURRENT
STATE -- SUICIDE AND YOU KNOW
OTHER.
ISSUES THAT ARE RELATED TO
MENTAL ILLNESS ARE AT AN ALL
TIME HIGH AND AGAIN THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT GETTING --
THE AXIS THAT THEY NEED TO
SERVICES -- ONE OF THESE CASES
ACTUALLY RESULT IN WHAT IS NOW
KNOWN AS THE FRANCO ROLLING --
SO WHAT HAPPENED WITH THIS CASE
THERE WAS ONE INDIVIDUAL MISTER
JOSE ANTONIO FRANKEL GONZALEZ --
HE WAS DETAINED -- FOR FIVE
YEARS WITH NO HEARING OR A
LAWYER IN THIS FAMILY WAS UNABLE
TO LOCATE HIM DURING THAT TIME.
AND SO ALTHOUGH -- THAT CASE DID
RESULT IN SOME PROTECTIONS --
CALIFORNIA'S STILL HAS A LONG
WAY TO GO IN ORDER -- TO TO
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE
ACCESS.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
REQUEST THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT SB.
THREE NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS.
ALL RIGHT OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
KEVIN AS THE CHORUS TO
CALIFORNIA ROUGH RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL MCNULTY STAY COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I THINK THE
TWO GETS ITS IMPORTANCE THE WHEN
WE SEE THAT THERE IS AN ISSUE.
THEY WOULD TRY TO FIND WAYS TO
TO SOLVE IT AND I THINK
ESPECIALLY HERE YOU HAVE LOOKED
TO THE THE FEDERAL REGULATIONS.
TO TO BRING US TO A BETTER PLACE
AND THANK YOU I FOR THAT THE
TAIL END OF YOUR TEST MY
APPRECIATE.
THAT YOU HAVE COME HERE TO GIVE
PERSONAL TESTIMONY ABOUT THIS.
SO WE HAVE A FIRST BY MISTER
GIBSON SECOND BY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY GOOD LET'S
TAKE REAL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
RIGHT YES HI RAY AS I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA.
CHOI.
CHOICE I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE
[inaudible]
ARAMBULA HI.
THANKS TO THE ALL RIGHT THAT
BILL HAS. SIX A CURRENTLY AT SIX
TWO ZERO WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MOTION WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE'S A MOTION BY.
THIS IS SECOND BY MISTER GIBSON.
CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE TAKE
ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
RADIUS HI RAY AS I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I'D
CHOI.
CHOICE I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE
[inaudible] SIXTY THREE THE
CARD VOTED SIX TO ZERO WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WHY DON'T WE?
GO BACK -- TO PRIOR ITEMS
[inaudible]
ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NINE I'M SORRY FILE
ITEM FIVE SB THREE SIXTY FIVE
CURRENT VOTERS FOUR TO ZERO
RIGHT YES HI RES I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I FRIEDMAN.
STONE.
CURRENT VOTE.
SIXTY ZERO FILE ITEM.
SIX SB THREE NINETY EIGHT
CURRENT VOTER SIX TO ZERO
FRIEDMAN.
STONE.
CURRENT VOTE.
SIXTY ZERO FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
FOUR SEVENTY CURRENT VOTERS FOUR
TO ZERO RIGHT YES HI RES I
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I FRIEDMAN.
STONE.
CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM NINE SB
SEVEN THIRTY FIVE CURRENT VOTE
FIVE TO ZERO FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE STONE CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO THANK YOU WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
.
HI PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
VOTED SIX TO ZERO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE STONE STONE AYE
FINAL VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM FIVE SB
THREE SIXTY FIVE CURRENT VOTED
SIX TO ZERO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN ICE STONE STONE I FINAL
VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT.
FILE ITEM SIX SB THREE NINETY
EIGHT CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ZERO
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE STONE STONE AYE
FINAL VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO BILLS
OUT.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AS BEFORE
SEVENTY CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TO
ZERO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE STONE STONE I FINAL
VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO THAT'S BILLS
OUT FILE ITEM NINE SB SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE CURRENT VOTED SIX TO
ZERO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE STONE STONE AYE
FINAL VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT ON THE CONSENT BILLS
ARE OUT AS WELL.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH THIS
CONCLUDES OUR HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE HEARING